These are serious,
like when you think about this,
like you probably shouldn't smoke too many of these because it's just plain
tobacco.
I love,
I love him.
Now I got to the point where I couldn't smoke joints.
I couldn't smoke out of a bong a pipe.
It had to be a backward,
that's where I am.
Yeah,
fine.
I love it.
I like him.
Did you ever smoke cigarettes?
No.
See I did.
I smoked a lot of cigarettes and then I quit smoking cigarettes.
Just smoked weed and then I discovered backwards and I was kinda getting a
little bit of both.
No,
still getting it tobacco that I missed.
Um,
but yeah.
Yeah.
My friend Ari said that he started smoking spliffs in England,
you know,
and when he was over in the UK,
the next,
the weed with the tobacco and he got totally hooked on tobacco again cause he
had quit cigarettes for years and then he started smoking the weed mixed with
the tobacco.
And before he knew it he was smoking cigarettes again.
Yeah.
So he smoked while he was over there and then he quit as soon as he was done.
And then came back to you.
US.
Yeah.
I feel like they just started smoking.
Just pure weed over there,
Jeff,
for years.
For years.
It was both.
Yeah.
I don't understand that.
I kind of that,
how'd that work out over there?
Yeah.
I don't know.
So illegal over there too.
It's like Jesus fucking Christ.
It's 2019 fellas.
Scary at times when I used to fly over there,
we'd have to tape tons of weed to our nuts just,
just to be able to,
and our road cases just so we could smoke over there cause they had dirt,
weed,
you know,
it was horrible.
We'd,
but yeah,
it was a pain in the ass.
It's fucking dangerous bringing that stuff overseas though.
If you get arrested,
that's,
that's serious.
Yeah.
I brought it aside.
Bring it everywhere like that.
And we went to Iran tape,
uh,
like gaff tape,
which is Jesus,
man.
I feel like you teared up the first layer of your nuts off when you go to grab
your weed.
But yeah,
we would do that.
And then,
uh,
it's a commitment though.
Yeah,
I actually brought it,
I made the big mistake of not bringing a bunch,
but I got to Iraq,
we went to Iraq for like right when the war broke out.
What was it like 2003 or 2004 and we were over there and,
and a scandalous Esteban oil,
the photographer,
he's over there with us documenting the whole thing and I pull it out cause
we're at this,
this airport and ball rain,
but I feel like it's a field and no one's gonna mess with us.
And he's like,
hey bro,
look,
look at,
look at the back of your fucking passport.
Look what it says.
And it says right there,
like you're basically like,
they'll kill you if they,
if they find,
you know,
you brought any drugs and die Iraq or you know,
where we were a ball rain.
So I did away with everything and I just kind of took up drinking.
And I'm not really much of a drinker,
but do you still smoke weed?
I don't know.
I have a friend who's like a dear friend is like a cool like young doctor named
Doctor [inaudible] in San Diego and I called them.
He actually removed my,
my tonsils and then like a week later I found out I had what was called
precancer Barrett's esophagus.
I said,
what does this mean Dr. Beach?
I just like Kinda like Kinda like tone down like how much I'm smoking.
And he's like,
no,
this means like this is your warning shot.
Like pay attention,
stop smoking.
Cancer is a rough one too.
That's what killed Christopher Hitchens.
Really?
Yeah.
That's a,
that's a rough one.
That kills a lot of fucking people.
Once you get it,
you get it and you're gone.
Basically.
It's cute.
I think kills like think hitch said like 95% of the people didn't get it.
Yeah.
So I felt like he,
he's always pretty honest with me and I,
I just stopped.
Like I love CVD.
Yeah.
That's pretty much what I messed with it now,
but that's all.
Do you find that a lot of people use CBD and they find that it alleviates
anxiety and let them sleep better?
Do you find that?
Yeah,
as long as I take like triple or quadruple the amount that it says to take on
the bottle because I feel like would I take,
if I take what the proper dosages,
it doesn't do much,
but I'm one of those people whose minds racing constantly.
I'll get home from the studio at one or two and I'm just like kind of like
figuring out how long I got to sleep before I get to wake up my kids and go to
school.
And I just sat there with my wheel spinning unless I use CBD.
And then that kind of helps.
And then I had,
I have what's called trigeminal neuralgia.
Have you ever heard of that?
No.
Oh,
it's the fucking worst.
It's called the suicide disease because basically all of your nerves in your
face or firing all at the same time.
So it almost feels like what you feel when you think you need a root canal or
you have like a tooth that's messed up.
But I got trigeminal Neuralgia and I've only had four episodes.
But when I do get it,
I use CBD and it,
it's been amazing.
But if you look it up,
a lot of people go actually go to a dentist,
get a bunch of root canals done that they don't need or they don't know how to
treat it.
And usually people kill themselves.
Whoa.
Yeah,
it's nor that didn't really know about it.
I just was home one day.
I was like,
what the fuck?
Like my face is burning.
It's misery
pink condition that affects the trigeminal nerve,
which carries a sensation for your face to your brain if you have trigeminal
Neuralgia,
even mild stimulation of your face,
such as from brushing your teeth or putting on makeup may trigger a jolt of
excruciating pain.
Holy Shit Man.
Yeah.
What,
what is the cause?
What causes that?
All different things.
They thought like mine,
I maybe got mine from impact like from my accident and then maybe little
sparring that I've done has,
has triggered it.
Um,
also dental,
when I get dental work done,
it triggers it.
So,
but the CBD stops it.
Yeah.
CBD in it.
If it's really bad,
there's,
um,
this medication called Gabapentin.
Uh,
and I feel like that's been a real great way to kind of like mass the pain and
one,
once the Gabapentin calms the nerve kind of Dad's the nerve,
24,
48 hours,
it's gone.
If it's a really bad episode of it's not so bad,
CBD just keeps it away.